sinks
sink stinks
sinks stinks
yeah
welcome to my presentation 2021 i hate
syncs and by the end of this i hope you
will hate syncs as well
we're going to cover some sync facts
some history behind sinks and
why sinks suck
reason why number one why sync stinks
you may ask what is the reason
zero improvement okay there's been no
innovation in the sink industry
example a here's what cars look like 500
years ago
here's what cars looks like today okay
and the same example
here's what syncs looked like 500 years
ago here's what they look today there's
been no change
any other field
humanity has improved except sync sync
design is bad and i'm going to explain
why here we have the ls
it's a chinese piece of i hate this
sink it's stainless steel which is not
stainless let's get real here i've never
in my life seen a stainless steel stain
steel
it's always stained it's the biggest
scam in modern history how are they
getting away with this
number two it's a top fitted sink it's
garbage you might have to throw it out
when it hurt dang and it's got a
sideboard like it's the 1980s and people
are still washing their dishes by their
hands the only thing worse than the ls
is if it had a double fitted sink
disgusting i don't even want to look at
it reason 2 the cup and the sink i'm
gonna call out a lot of you here the cup
in the sink the fatal cup in the sink
for some reason people seem to think
that leaving a cup in the sink it just
goes away you can't see it anymore
i see
things are misused a fatal flaw people
don't even use sinks the way they are
supposed to be used okay it's not your
garbage disposal it's not where the cups
goes it's not the dishwasher can we stop
doing this please why do people do this
i will never understand because things
sings that's why i hate them stupid
stinks move on i can't even look at this
i actually went to do some research on
this and i found that people are
actually getting divorced because people
leave cups in the sink something to
think about let that sink in i just came
up with that on the fly all right recent
three since
there's always since america has figured
out the problem where they have those
things in horror movies that goes
right and it takes care of all the crap
i assume
i like to believe there's some hope for
humanity that they fixed it but with
europeans we just don't do anything we
just be like it's sink gunk i like that
i like saying gunk i don't want i don't
want the waste disposal thing no no i
like i like all the sh and gun
collecting in there and smelling weird
that's what i want so this is what it
looks like in a sink 99 of the time
let's get really yeah it does thanks so
people invented these
these this is the standard every
sink has that one they all look like
that or the one that has holes in it and
it comes up like a basket those are the
only two options are you kidding me
those are terrible it still looks like
it doesn't solve the problem and those
are impossible to wash because you wipe
them and everything gets stuck in
between how do you wash that i don't
know
it's pissed i'm getting pissed off what
do people do when they this is the
problem with sings we put a lid on it
amazing fix the problem right it's still
there why don't you put a lid on the
whole goddamn sink then what's the point
i don't get it and stop pretending it's
stainless steel like that it's not going
to be stained it's arm i hate it i don't
get it
i don't okay reason four this one
thing can you believe this okay this
might be exclusive to britain and
british people for some reason don't
want to admit that this is the most
up thing they're like yeah it's
over here hey the job will sink yeah so
you get two options i'm not even joking
this is common this is everywhere you
get the this blazing hot water option
the left one or you're freezing cold
which one will you choose huh you want
to burn off your hands or even freeze
your hands that you let me know which
one you would prefer
that's the only options there's no in
between they exist like this is satan's
reincarnated literally i don't
understand it it blew my mind when i see
it everywhere here they're an
infestation and before you get all tom
scott rich me my reason why is we've got
victorian plumbing yeah and we could be
it's not an excuse okay every other
country has figured out and you know why
it's not an excuse as well because
they're still doing them they're still
being made people like it they're like
oh it's like a victorian style sink i
love victorian blazing hot whoa
why
you can't answer why because you're dumb
don't even answer it because i don't
want to hear it oh it's because uh
crossing the streams make it a little
illegal okay good
what is this animation god damn it
reason number five that's right i can go
all day literally i had to cut it down
the plumbing okay it makes no sense it's
ass design it's ash the same trap makes
sense in principle because you're
trapping water there so a bunch of
smells from the sewage will not come out
i approve it but why is it so annoying
to remove and clean the damn things they
get clogged all the time because reason
number three those little
take out thingaroonies they don't work
right food still gets in the sink so it
clogs up and you have to clean it
eventually that's normal but look at
this where would i even know where to
look to clean this i need to take out
two points of one part and then it's
gonna leak everywhere it makes no sense
there's too many points of failure as
well it could leak anyway look at that i
would have to screw three things just to
take out one thing that's too many
screws i don't like that look at this
garbage what is that this is normal
google search by the way that's normal
sink material right there i'm not cherry
picking british people will think i'm
cherry i'm not why
are pipes not see-through
at least then i know
where the gunk is and i know which one
of these figures i have to remove right
and why
are they shaped like that and not just
straight down and then to the side so
then i can just screw out here and then
gun goes out right that would make sense
why is there not like a thing i
can spin to release the gunk i don't
know i don't know how to sing i'm not a
plumber i just think this is this is the
best we can do we went to the moon okay
just think about that reason seven
the splash
don't even get me started on the splash
my god have it you yeah it's like a dead
meme at this point you ever put a spoon
in the sink and then it's
i hate it why does it come from the top
can we come from the side and not splash
everywhere getting emotional this is how
it is this is what sings to me
everyone's been splashed everyone can
relate to this problem no one likes
getting splashed i don't like getting
spiked you don't like it we could solve
this if we work together and the biggest
problem is sometimes you know the
pressure is so high on these goddamn
things it splashes your crotch and as a
guy
it looks like you peed yourself and it's
and then you go out and everyone's like
oh look he peed himself and he's like no
it's a splash from the sink the
the sink did it not me i swear and then
no
so those are the seven reasons why i
don't like syncs thank you for watching
this presentation
subscribe
for more content on why things are bad
thank you
you